人類の中には
全ての動物たちだよ
今日はちょっとそんな話をしてみたいと思います
私は現在ですね
生物の進化や生態系が人の心のうつしかがみになっていて
一人ひとりの個人の人生やそれから文化とか文明といったものも
生命原理で子ずーっとつながって
一つのものであるということを様々な形で表現する活動をしています
この活動を通しているうちに来いくつかいろんなことを思うようになったんですがその
中で今日は一つ思ったことを紹介したいと思います
人のも人の心の子がは
まるでノアの方舟の要であるということを今日お話ししたいと思います
自我がノアの箱舟と言われても皆さんちょっときょとんとしちゃうかもしれないんです
がまずはこのことをお話しするために
一つユニークな概念を紹介します
それは
環世界というものですたぶんおそらくここにいる皆さん
環世界という言葉は
聞いたことないんじゃないかと思います
これはですねドイツの
生物学者で哲学者の
行くスキルという人がね提唱した概念です
この形はまああの主に谷を研究している人なんですけどもあるといいですね
こんなことを考えました自分が公園にいて1匹の犬がいるのに気がついた
でそこには木があっ
まあダニの研究者なんであそこに気があるならまあ犬がしたを通りかかったらダニが
狙って落っこちるなぁなんてことを考えてなんですね
でまぁそんな彼にとっては愛触れた風景を
見ているうちにこんなことを思います
あれ
私は今ここに犬が開いて公園があって犬外敵があってダニがいるって考えているけど
ダニにとっては
私も犬もキモましてはこの公園も存在してないんだなっていうことを考えたそうです
それはどういうことかというと第二にはまず目がありません
何が使える期間っていうのは聴覚あすいません収穫と触覚だけなんですね
で彼らは非常にを変わった習性をしていて
とりあえず高いところに登りますで高いところに登ったら
酢酸のにおいに反応して酢酸の匂いが自分よりも下の方からすると手を離すという習性
を持っています
手を放すとこう怒ってるわけですけども落っこった時に何かたい暖かくってふわっとし
たものの上に乗っかったらくるっと振り向いて頭もぶっさして
千代子昼夜と数とまあそういう
ああああああ
世界に来ています
で例えばまあ風が吹いたり釜を落っこってみたら
うまくいきまのの上に落ちずに地面に落ちることもあるわけですね
そういうときはとりあえず
感触が違うわけですねを持っているものとそうしたらとりあえずどこでもいいから高い
ところに上がるそうです
彼らはそういった反応世界の中で生きていて私たちが思うような空間イメージがあり
ません
女もないし匂いといっても反応するのは自分にとって大事な
酢酸汗のニオイだけです
まあ犬の上に落っこちた金子の上に落ちたかあるいは汗臭行くスキルの上に落ちたか
その辺は全然おかまいなしなわけです
そうやって考えたときに行くスクールは自分たちがこういうふうに五幕を見ている世界
こういうのを誰もがそしてどんな生き物もが共有してるって言うのは大きな勘違いじゃ
ないかと思うようになりました
まーだになんていうのは極端な例ですがその犬もまた違う世界を見ているし一つ一つの
動物が全部違う世界に見ている
私たちは同じ世界にいると思っているけれども自分たちの感覚が見ている世界でその
答えなり種形が見られる体験できる世界というのは限られています
そこに閉じ込められた環境世界に閉じ込められているのではないかと考えました
行くスクールの間世界というものなんですけども
環世界
環境世界の略です
生命が自分の五感を持って近くしている環境に閉じ込められてい
まぁ一応ねちょっと交換世界に閉じ込められているというイメージで
間にそれぞれ閉じ込められている cg になってるんですけどあのこれ間違えたらの
間が缶詰の関東覚えないでください
あの環境の間です
イメージがあるんでねでまぁこういうふうに缶詰のに閉じ込められてるんだけどでも
総合
関係を持っています総合世界は気づいているので
あのそれぞれの感覚で同じ宇宙に住んでいると思ってというふうに考えました
まぁ実際に例えば私たちにとって身近なさっきのよくスキルにも出てきましたけど犬
ですね
犬なんか犬に限らずほとんどの哺乳類は
2色の色しか見えませんそうするとちょっと上の方の写真に出てるんですけども
赤い唐辛子と真緑の
唐辛子みたいなもんが並んでたときにほとんどの動物にとって赤と色が存在していない
のでまったく区別がつきません
特にあの犬なんかもそうなんですけども犬なんか鼻が強いですけどね草食動物とか
羊とかそういったものなら草さえ食べればいいので赤いものにあんま興味ないとユリス
概念がないです
それに対して私たち人類はなんで赤いものが見えるかというと私たちの先祖のサルは
木の実が
熟しているものを食べましただから赤が大事です
なので赤のある世界に住んでますそれからまあもう全く違う見方をしている動物たちが
一ついっぱいいるわけですけれども
イルカなんかは資格は弱くていわゆる音拠点にソナーで世界を見ています
そんなをてみるということはこれはまさに大人んだけど見るなんですね形状や形は取れ
ます
それから
目で見るのと違って質感とか版寄ったんで身体の中とかもわかります
全然また違った臨場感を持った世界に住んでいるんですね
それから覚めなんかだとローレン家に期間というのがあってね生体電位がわかるそう
です
だから変なちちょっと小動物が動こうともタイミングがそれでわかったり岩の後ろに
いる生き物なんかも察知できます
このようにねそれぞれ違った世界に住んで
わけですけれどもじゃあ我々人間はどうかというと私たちは人間のこの後感を持った体
を持っているのでそこに一つの間世界を確かに持っているんですが一番特徴的なのは
もう一つ複雑な言語をもって世界観を私たちは持っていますその世界観
また自己イメージとかによってもう一つ間世界を持っています
でしかもこのもう一つの間世界それぞれ皆さん違います
いわゆる二階です
私たちは自我を保つことによって一人一人がものすごく個性的な存在になりました
価値観や行動原理が一人一人違います
なので同じ体験同じものを見ても感じ方は違うし場合によっては見ているもの見えてる
ものすら違います興味があるものしか見えなかったりしますか
よく作りはやっぱり人間に対しても間世界のイメージをしていました
例えば古い大きな木があったときその木を見た時に空想好きな少女はそこに紅葉生の
存在を感じたり
何かこう古めかしい魔法使いのなんかこう
呪術的な音ものに使われるんじゃないかって想像したりするかもしれないけど
木こりにとってはこの木を切ったらいくらになるだろうとか
ここは切らずに残し
といた方がいいとかまぁお金に見えるとまあそういうわけです
まぁこんな風に動物は手で間世界で決まっています
環世界というのは生き方です動物は主=生き方です
人間は
人類というのでは皆同じ間世界を共有していますけど
子がで一人一人が違う間世界を持っています
なので首都家がワカな世界という意味で同じものではないかと考えました
私はそれをシュッと自我が同じ係をしているということで種が同型論と名付けています
人類の中にはですねまあ一人一人個性的な生き方をしていますこれがまるで全ての動物
に匹敵するかのような
まあ間世界ですね多様性を持ってこんなたった五種類
あの人間は白人黒人黄色人種って言いますけど生物学的に行ったらたった五種類の主
です
たった五種類なのにこれだけバラバラの生き方をしてあのそれによって新たな可能性を
つくっているのは存在は
生命史上全くいません人類に近いと言われたネアンデルタール人もどうも調べてみると
同じような設計を作り続けたり
知能とかは合格同じぐらいあったはずなのに多様性がありませんでした次回だ
おそらく発達してなかったんだと思います
人類
ある意味こうやってこういう世界まで作って発展したのは何かをイメージして作り出し
たり
世界観を持っているからですけども私たちはひょっとしたらこの進化の必然の過程の中
で
全生命の多様性の可能性を言っ種類の存在で
受け止めて進化したのかもしれません声明は種の多様性によって地球環境のあらゆる
困難とか変換を乗り越えてフォロー日内で完全に滅びることはなく生き続けました
そういった多様性を最終的に人類は一種類で手に入れることができたのです
だけどちょっと困ったこともあります
私たちは同じ人類だっていう前提でコミュニケーションしてるんですけれどもこう思っ
てくださいここにいるのは同じ人間じゃなくて野生の王国だと思ってみたい
隣にいる人たちは同じ土精神を持ってないかもしれません
で例えばこんな事が起きるかも知れませ
狼の親がオオカミタイプの人が親でその親が覚めのこういうのかもしれないんです
ためタイプのこと
そうするとどちらも大きい顎を持ったり捕食者なんですけれども
サメの子は草原をさっそうと走ることはできません
でもオオカミにとっては草原を颯爽と走れることが大事なことです
だから愛があるゆえにサメの子一生懸命走れるように育てようとします
でもこれはサメの子にとってはとっても苦しい事です
まあこういったことは結構あるのかも知れません人間の中にある
でも染めは親から1回離れて自分の海っていう場所を見つけたなら親のサメ以上に自由
に泳ぎ回って可能性を追求するでしょう
まあ私はこういった考え方ができるようになって
ひとりひとりの人たちの個性とかまあ自分とは違う考えがあってもなんていうのかな
受け入れやすくなりました
まあこういった考えによってない人間関係が楽になったんですね
まあこういったことが私たちの子がはまるで方舟のようである
ノアは
破滅の時にすべての動物を一つ回ずつ箱舟に入れて
種の対応性を護ろうとしました私たち人類は声明の中で進化して同じ種の中に全生命に
匹敵する対応性を抱え込みました
これが人類の大きな可能性じゃないかと思います
最後に私たちは道具や科学の力でですね
実際に見えないものを見えるようになってます本来の人間の能力だ
危険日今日だとか電波望遠鏡だとかレーダーとかでこれはまさに
ある意味生物の種の間世界の限界を超えたことになります
いるかのような音響
お体もしてますねつまり生物的な間世界は完全に
統合して超えましたそして二階によって一人一人がまるで生態系のようになっています
一人一人が生態系のようになっているんですけれどももし
人類というものが主というものが持っている制限
種の限界を超えて進化した存在だとしたらひょっとしたらこれからの人類は一人一人が
持っている子が
このジガーの制限を乗り越えて次の段階に行こうとしているのかも知れませ
つまり一人ひとりが自分を豊かに成長させていくことそれがイコールそのまんま
人類の進化それは人類という単位の進化ではなくてずっとつながってきた
38億年の全生命の進化につながっているんじゃないかと思います
まあ以上経が皆さんにお伝えしたいことでしたありがとうございました
ティッカーありがとうございました
聞こえますか今日いますね皆さん面白かったなぁ